what i hope to do in this video is a
bunch of examples to show us that a lot
of the properties we've been dealing
with in arithmetic the distributive
property associative property
commutative property that these apply
just as well to negative numbers but
with that said it is good to actually
see it used using using negative numbers
or see these properties applied just to
make sure that we we understand what's
going on so these exercises these are
all from khan academy whoops so this
first one says which of the following
expressions are equivalent to negative 2
times the quantity 5 minus 3. now you
could of course just figure out what
that 5 minus 3 is 2 and then multiply
that times negative 2 and you would get
negative 4 and you can see which of
these is equal to negative 4 and that
would be fair but the whole point of
this video is to understand that look
maybe i could apply the distributive
property here
so let's do that so what i could do is i
could distribute this negative 2. i
could multiply it times 5
and then i could multiply it by i could
either view it as
it's going to be negative 2 times 5
plus
negative 2 times negative 3 or you could
view it as negative 2 times 5 minus
negative 2 times positive 3. now let me
write those two things down
so you could view this as negative two
times five
negative two times five
plus
negative
negative two times negative 3
you could view it that way or you could
view it as
negative 2
negative 2 times 5
minus
and if i'm putting a minus here then i'm
going to view this as a positive 3 that
we're subtracting a positive 3 so minus
negative 2 times positive 3. notice i
either wrote the negative here and wrote
a positive here i wrote the negative
here and made this a positive 3. but
these are going to be equivalent either
way i've distributed this negative 2.
notice i have a negative 2 negative 2.
and what are these going to be equal to
well
negative 2 times 5 is negative 10
and then
negative two times negative three is
positive six
or over here negative two times three is
negative six but then we subtract it so
it's gonna get positive you're gonna get
positive six either way this right over
here is positive six
and this over here subtracting a
negative 6 would give you
positive 6. so you get negative 10 plus
and that's this choice right over here
which of course does evaluate to
negative 4 which would which this
expression does evaluate to this one up
here evaluates to negative 16. and of
course i won't select this because i
found an answer let's do several more
which of the following expressions are
equivalent to negative s
times t times s select all that apply
and here we can't just substitute we
can't just evaluate it and see oh what
does this these evaluate to we should we
should do a little bit of a manipulation
of these variables
well there's a couple of ways to think
about it one we could change the order
in which we multiply these things so we
could view this as
negative s
that's that let me write it a little bit
neater
we could view it as
negative s
times
s
s times t
times whoops let me do that in a
different color
times s
times t times t
and do any of the choices look like that
well almost this instead of saying
negative s times s this says s times
negative s
and because multiplication once again
you know i i'm not a big fan of using
the word because it sounds complicated
but just it's it's commutative
a times b is the same thing as b times a
so i can rewrite this as
i can rewrite this i can swap these two
and write this as s
times
s times
negative s
times t
all i did is i swapped these two
this negative s
and this s i just swapped them and i got
exactly what i have right over here
now let's just make sure that this one
does not apply and maybe the easiest way
is to try to simplify this and the best
way i could think about that is by
distributing this s
so if i distribute this s
what i'm going to get this is going to
be equal to
s times t which is s t
or i could even i can write it like this
i could write it s times t like that
and then i have
minus s times s so minus
s times s
i could write it that way or i could
write minus
s squared if i want to that's the same
thing as s times s but this is very
different
this is very different here i'm just
taking the product of three variables
here i have two different terms taking
the product of two variables here and
then the product i guess you could say
i'm taking s squared or i'm taking s
times s so this is not this is not the
same thing
which of the following expressions are
equivalent to negative x times and then
in parentheses negative y times x and i
if i forgot to mention it but like
always pause the video try to work them
out by yourself before i do them
all right select all that apply
so let's just try to manipulate this a
little bit so once again multiplication
it's associative i could i could that's
negative x times
times negative y
times x
so the way it's written here
i could do these first that's
essentially what's written over here or
it's associative i instead i could do
these first and the reason why i find
this interesting is a negative times a
negative is going to be a positive so
this is going to be the same thing
this thing over here is going to be the
same thing as positive x times positive
y negative times a negative is a
positive so you're going to get positive
x times y and then you're multiplying by
an x again
multiplying by an x again now the other
thing we know about multiplication is
it's commutative we can change the order
in which we multiply because i don't see
i don't see this quite i don't see this
going on over here yet so let's see if i
change the order if i put the x's if i
multiply the x's first i could write
this as
i could write this as
x
times
x times x times y
times y all i did is i swapped these two
once again i can swap the order when i'm
multiplying and i don't quite see this
yet but x times x that's the same thing
as x squared this thing right over here
that's x squared so this is going to be
x squared
x squared times y which is exactly what
we have over there
now what does this one up evaluate to
and this one actually evaluates to a
number because regardless of what x you
pick x minus x that's going to be zero
zero times anything is going to be 0. so
this thing is going to be equal to 0. so
this is different than what's going on
over here so i definitely would not pick
that
let's do one more
which of the following expressions are
equivalent to a
times negative 10 plus 11. well once
again my you know the instant when you
see something like y i'd love to
distribute that a it's just sitting
there
so let's do that a times negative 10
would be negative 10
times a or negative 10 a
and then a
times 11
so it's going to be plus
a times 11 is the same thing as 11 times
a which we could write as 11
a
now which of these choices are that
negative 10 a plus 11a
so this is negative 10a plus 11a so this
one looks right now what about this one
well here they just swapped the order if
you put the 11a first
you could write it this way you could
write if you write the 11a first
we could write
11a
and we have instead of saying it
negative 10a we just say minus
10a once again i just took all i did is
i took
this thing and i put it
out front so these two things are
actually equivalent so i would select
that one as well